Jim is in Louisiana hi Jim welcome to
the Dave Ramsey show hi Dave thanks for
taking my call
sure what's up we're kind of in crisis
mode I mean we're just living paycheck
to paycheck and we make way too much
money to do that
how much do you make just don't I
probably I Drive a truck for a living so
I probably make 50,000 or better a year
and my wife makes seventy five thousand
a year
mm-hmm yeah you do make too much money
we broke so why are you broke yeah I
don't know how yeah you do talk about it
well we have well forty thousand credit
card debt seventy-five thousand dollars
in student loans to cars that we can't
afford yep for you Oh in the cars
um 2016 Jeep Compass eighteen nineteen
thousand right before we were married
she came home with a brand new Mustang
so I don't know what she owes on that 20
25 how long you been married we've been
married about a year we just celebrated
our one-year anniversary okay well we
you know if it were my house I would sit
down with her and just say this is not
working we're both working our butts off
we make a lot of money and we're
completely broke the plan that we are
using sucks beyond belief mm-hmm agreed
I have yeah and I've done that and I've
suggested several times that we try to
work your plan and she says to me that
she makes too much money to live like
she's broke so she's a princess she's a
princess broke yeah by the way you are
broke and by the way the number one
caused a divorce in North America Dave's
money fights and money problems Prince's
right I make too much money to live like
I'm broke and yet you keep buying crap
and spending money like you're in
Congress how old is this girl
we're both yeah I'm 44 she's 45 Wow too
old to be acting that way
I don't know I mean if she can 90% of
solving a problem is realizing there
isn't one and if we can't agree that the
process that you all have used to get
here and where you are today sucks then
I don't know where to start from there
she had agreed I bought her a total
money makeover and she's agreed to read
that this weekend okay well that's a
good start
I mean you know I you know you cannot
continue to do what you're doing would
you agree with that oh I totally agree
and if she would if she can agree to
that then you say okay what do you what
are we gonna do because what we're doing
now we can't keep doing and her answer
to that is well I'm good at making a
budget
no I'm saying she should answer that
right that's her that's her answer oh
I'm good at making a budget yeah when
yeah I don't know she ever has been yet
she bought a Mustang she couldn't afford
that doesn't indicate she's good at
making a budget that's delusional no
she's not good at making a budget y'all
suck at handling money and I'm not mad
at you and I'm trying to trying to shame
you I'm just agreeing with you and I'm
sorry you're in this pain so what you
guys have got to do is establish that
there is a legitimate problem here and
what is our best source of information
and our best plan to change our
behaviors so we get a different result
the 12-steppers say continuing to do the
same thing over and over again and
expecting a different result
is the definition of insanity which is
what y'all have done today and I think
you're on the fried track and I think
you need to quit proposing what we need
to do instead of let's start first
talking about that there is a problem
there's a problem there's a problem
there's a problem that you notice we're
broke as we work like animals and we
have no money did you notice that
I think you need to let the problem
settle in on everybody because
everybody's been walking around in
denial